[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: All righty.
Hi, everybody, and thanks
for coming to this session.
My name is Laurence Moroney.
I work as a developer advocate
on the Google Brain team.
I'm primarily focused on
TensorFlow, machine learning,
and AI.
I've just come from
another session,
so I'm doing
back-to-back sessions.
And if you were at the previous
session, some of this material
you probably have seen already.
So forgive me for the duplicate.
And because I know there's a
lot of folks waiting outside--
so if we can kind of shove up.
And maybe if there's some room
for the folks to come in--
or if you're outside
and you can hear this,
we're repeating this
session on Thursday morning.
So take a look, and we'll see.
And if you want to
hear the session,
there's a repeat of it
being done on Thursday.
So I'm here today to talk a
little bit about TensorFlow
and to introduce
you to TensorFlow.
But I always like to begin
with the question, what
is AI anyway, right?
You know, you turn on the
news, you open a newspaper,
you browse the web, and you
see people talking about AI.
And you know, you
probably see pictures
like these, of CGI androids,
or predicting the future,
or maybe things
that are even worse.
And you read a lot of doom
and gloom scaling from AI
is taking our jobs to AI is
the next Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie.
And it's all of these things.
And I find that maybe
we, as an industry,
have done a pretty bad job of
explaining what AI actually is.
We talk a lot
about what it does.
But we rarely talk about
what it actually is,
and particularly from a
programming perspective.
So actually, quick question--
how many people here
are developers who write code?
OK, a lot of you, cool.
So you're the right audience.
So what is AI anyway?
I like to talk about it
in terms of writing code.
And I like to talk about machine
learning in particular in terms
of writing code.
So say, for example,
if I wanted to write
an application which is a
classifier of cats versus dogs.
OK, how would you do
that, being a coder?
We all write code that's like,
if this, then that, while this,
do that, all these
kind of things.
But how would you do that for a
classifier of cats versus dogs?
Like, say I gave it this image.
And this image is--
as a human being, you're
going to take a look at that,
and you say, that's a cat.
Why do you say that's a cat?
There's probably
some features on it
that you recognize that are very
catlike, like the pointy ears,
right?
So you go, OK.
You look at that, and
you say that it's a cat.
And you think about
that as a programmer.
You might say, if has
pointy ears, then cat.
But in order to
get that, you have
to process the
image somehow, find
where the ears are
in the image somehow,
and determine that
they're pointy somehow.
It's very complex,
very hard to do.
But then I'd show
you this image.
OK, is this a cat?
It's not, right?
It's a dog.
But it's got pointy ears.
And as a result,
we go, huh, OK, I
can't just say if has
pointy ears, then cat.
And then I show this image.
And it's like, OK, this has
got really pointy ears, OK?
Now, is that a cat,
or is it some kind
of weird science-fiction
creature?
I don't know.
It's got very
strange ears to me.
And so I go, OK, so
there's where I'm
confused as a developer, OK?
It's going to be very hard
for me to write all the image
processing and write
all the if-thens and all
these kind of things to
figure out, OK, which is a dog
and which is a cat.
And then I go, OK, there's
another feature of a dog
that we all know, and
it's like this, all right?
So it's like, if it's got a big,
long, floppy tongue like that,
it's probably a dog.
And in my case, I
usually write the rule,
like, if it's currently plotting
your murder, then it's a cat.
And if it will love you
for the rest of your life,
then it's likely to be a dog.
And then when I'm looking
at image like this
and trying to
classify them, then I
come up with a beauty
like this, which,
to me, is this is what
happens to a mogwai
when you feed them
after midnight.
But apparently
it's a dog as well.
But as a programmer,
it's really, really hard
for me to write some kind
of an application that
would determine this.
OK, not everybody needs
to write an application
of cats versus dogs.
But maybe you do need to write
some kind of classification
application-- spam
versus not spam, hot dog
versus not hot dog for
"Silicon Valley" fans,
and that kind of thing.
And how do you write
these classifiers?
And in traditional code,
that's very, very difficult.
Because traditional code
looks like this, right?
You've got your
classical programming.
You input the rules to that.
And your rules are the code
that we all make our bread
and butter off of, you know,
writing Java, or C++, or C#,
or Kotlin, or
Objective-C, or Swift,
or how many other languages
there are out there.
You know, that's the
rules that we write.
And usually, in classical
programming, we write rules,
and we have data.
And out of that comes answers.
So we write an application with
lots of rules in it to say,
it's pointy ears, it's a cat--
you know, those kind of things.
But the idea is
that, then, there
are a number of
scenarios that are really
easy to do with
this, but there are
scenarios that are practically
impossible to do with this.
You might be able to write a
cats versus dog classifier.
But think about the amount of
code that you'd have to write,
the amount of code that
you'd have to maintain.
And then suddenly, you get
another picture of a creature,
and you don't know if
it's a cat or a dog.
You'd probably have to
rewrite all your code again.
And it becomes infeasible
and difficult to do that.
Now, one of my favorite
things, I wear a smartwatch.
And on my smartwatch, it
has activity detection.
It knows when I'm
running, it knows
when I'm walking, it knows when
I'm swimming-- or in my case,
sinking.
And it knows all of these things
based on-- its being trained,
based on data, to say--
you know, the people who built
the smartwatch took thousands
and thousands of
people and said,
let's make them
walk and say this
is what it looks like
when you're walking
when you're wearing a watch.
Let's make them run.
This is what it looks
like when you're running
when you're wearing a watch.
Let's make them swim.
This is what it looks
like when you're
swimming when you're
wearing a watch,
and to actually train
a system off of that.
So it changes the
rules completely.
So instead you inputting
rules, and inputting data,
and getting out answers, the
concept of machine learning,
and the whole revolution
of machine learning,
is very simply, you input
answers, and you input data,
and you get out the rules.
So the idea behind this one is
you get lots and lots of data
to show something.
So for example, I get
thousands and thousands
of images of cats.
And I say, this is
what a cat looks like.
So the data are the images.
The answer is me saying
this what a cat looks like.
Same for dogs, same
for mogwai, same
for all these other things.
Or if I'm building a
watch, I get lots and lots
of data of people running,
I get lots and lots
of data of people walking,
and all of these things.
And I train it.
So as a result, it's opened
up all these new scenarios
for types of
applications that you
can build that would
be very difficult to do
with if-then kind of rules.
You know, some of the
early spam detectors
used a lot of if-then.
If the body contains
these particular words,
it's probably a spam.
If it's sent to you
Bcc, it might be a spam.
If it's sent from somebody
in your contact list,
it's probably not a spam--
all of these kind of things.
And you could kind of
get a good spam detector
with if-then rules.
But what if-- many of us receive
thousands of emails a day.
And we categorize
spam, not spam.
Well, what if that's
us giving the answers?
And then a machine learning
algorithm could take the data,
this is what a spam
looks like, this
is what a not spam looks like.
And as a result, you end up
getting vastly improved spam
filters, because they're
trained in that way.
So then the question becomes,
well, how do you train them?
So just show the
diagram again first.
So it's like, classical
programming, machine
learning-- very different.
We're just flipping the axes.
And the nice thing about
flipping those axes
is that it's opening up new
scenarios that I thought--
and I think the
industry has shown--
were previously close
to being impossible.
So I like to use an example.
And it's one thing that
I've been working on since I
started on machine learning.
And I've only been
working on this at Google
for about six months.
But the first project that I
took on when I was doing it
was to take a look at
breast cancer data.
Now if you think about breast
cancer data-- and in this case,
the data set that I was looking
at for breast cancer data had
about 30 different
data points for cells
in a biopsy around
breast cancer.
And these data points would
be things, for example,
such as the size of the cell,
the density of the cell,
the shape of it,
things like that.
And so with these 30
different data points,
you could conceivably
write lots of if-thens.
You know, if it's
above a certain size,
if it's a certain density,
if it's a certain shape,
then there's an increased
likelihood of it
being a breast cancer cell.
And you'd do something that
looks like this, right?
So the red ones on the
right are malignant.
Big ones are malignant,
green ones are benign.
Wouldn't it be really
nice if it was that easy?
You know, if x is greater
than 30, then it's malignant.
Else, it's benign.
But unfortunately, it's
not that easy, right?
Because then, if you
add a second axis to it,
it kind of looks like this.
And you've got a
little bit of overlap.
You can't just draw a
straight line down the middle
and say if x is greater than 30.
But you could probably
draw a line like this
and then say, OK, the ones above
and to the right of the line
are malignant.
And the ones below and to the
left of the line are benign.
And if you remember your
high school geometry,
you know the equation of a
line-- y equals mx plus c.
And if you can figure out what
the m is and you can figure out
what the c is, then you
can start saying, ah, now
maybe I can start making a
decision about what's malignant
and what's benign.
This is great.
That line, in machine
learning parlance,
is called a decision boundary.
But this is the
reality of the data.
This is what it looks like.
It's not really that simple.
So I've plotted this.
This is only three
dimensions that I'm plotting,
instead of-- there were
about 30 in the data set.
And the three dimensions
that I'm plotting
are the two that I showed
a moment ago, plus,
a third one is the
actual size of the cell.
So if you look closely,
the size of the blob
is proportional to
the size of the cell.
So you see the ones over on
the right are really big.
And the ones over on the
left are really small.
So even just plotting in
three dimensions of data,
then we've got a lot of mixed up
data right in the middle there.
So how do I draw a
decision boundary?
Do I draw it
something like this,
where most of the ones
on the right are red
and most of the ones
on the left are green?
You can't really do that
with something as important
as cancer, right?
You just can't depend
on that type of thing.
And also, if I zoom in,
and I start looking--
OK, it was the axes here,
with the smoothness,
the compactness,
and the concavity.
You can see, even
when I zoom in,
it's not really that
simple, that there
are reds amongst the
greens, and there
are greens amongst the reds.
It becomes very,
very difficult for me
to make a simple decision with
an if this, then that type
of algorithm.
So if I go back to
this, and I start
thinking about this
in machine learning
terms instead of traditional
programming terms--
and I'm going to say, OK,
the simplest example--
and I know this
isn't going to work,
because I'm only
training on one feature.
So when I said-- when you do
machine learning, remember,
you pass in the data,
you pass in the answers.
So when I'm talking
about features,
this is one of the
aspects of the cell.
I'm just going to
pick one of them.
In this case, it was the size.
And if I only train on one,
I know it's going to fail.
But I just want to
use this as an example
of how the process works.
So here it's a case of--
OK, in the case of a neural
network, I'm going to say--
I have this if-then.
If it's greater than
30, it was malignant.
If it's less than
30, then it's benign.
Well, what if I
created what I call
a layer in a neural network?
And the idea of that layer
is that it calculates
something called a weight.
And then the weight-- if
remember y equals mx plus c,
the weight is the m.
It's the slope of the line.
But we only have one axis
here, so it's even simpler.
So we'd say, OK, when we think
about this as a function,
well, we saw 18 was benign,
17 was benign, 13 was benign,
31, 35, and 39 were malignant,
it's really easy for me
to say, OK, in my
layer, I'm going
to call a function called ReLU.
ReLU is a common function
used in machine learning.
And it basically is the
same as writing the code,
if x is greater than 0,
then the output is x.
Otherwise the output is 0, OK?
The idea is it just allows you
to filter out negative values.
So I'm going to say, here--
I'm going to subtract
30 from the radius
and get the ReLU of that.
Greater than 0 is true.
0 is false.
And now I can start going, ah,
I now have made this decision.
I've created a really simple
network, which isn't really
a neural network at all.
But I'm able to say the weight
for this is 1, because it's
going to work all the time.
So the answer is going to be
1 times the ReLU of radius
minus 30.
This is all very
mathy stuff that
goes on in a neural network.
And fortunately,
you're not going
to need to know most of this.
But I want to show what's
happening under the hood.
So then if I go, OK,
so my second one is--
here it is in two axes.
And my decision
boundary is going
to look like this,
as we showed earlier.
And we have y equals mx plus c.
So in a neural network parlance,
what's that going to look like?
Well, I got two layers.
And these two layers, I'm going
to have one figure out my m,
which is the slope of the line.
And I'm going to have
one figure out my c.
And my output's going to
be y equals mx plus c.
So when I can figure out m,
and I can figure out the c,
or if a machine can learn what
the m is, and a machine can
learn what the c
is, now the machine
has that decision boundary that
it's figured out for itself.
And me, as a
programmer, I don't need
to write any code for that.
It's figured it out for me.
So now I can go, OK,
what if I initialize it
with a couple of random values,
something like this where
m equals 0 and c equals 5.
We can visualize that the
boundary looks like this.
But it's not a very
good one, right?
There's a lot of benign
cells above the line that
are showing up as malignant.
It's not horrible.
Because you're going
to tell somebody
that they have cancer when
they don't, which is not good.
But it's not as
horrible as telling them
that they don't have
it when they do.
But we go, OK, we
can learn from this.
Let's see if we can do better.
So what happens then
in your neural network
is it's going to say, OK,
I'm going to take that value,
draw that line with
those initial values.
I'm going to calculate
which ones are right
and which ones were wrong.
And based off of that, I can
figure out what my loss is.
And then I'll have a function
called a loss optimizer.
And all the loss
optimizer is is there
is a bunch of built in
mathematical functions that
say, you know what,
when you lose this much,
try tweaking your m to
this and your c to that.
And then see how much you lose.
And if you lose less, we're
heading in the right direction.
If you lose more, we're
heading in the wrong direction,
so we'll tweak
them the other way.
So those kind of
things TensorFlow
does for you automatically,
all that optimization,
all those loss functions.
So typically I'll get my
data, and I'll test that.
And I know the answers,
already, to this data.
So I'll keep going until
have a very low loss.
So when I come up
with an m and a c that
works for all of
my data, I now know
that I've trained a neural
network to make a decision
based on the boundary.
So for example, maybe it
goes to this and says,
OK, I'm going to try this value.
And this is a terrible value.
So even though my loss value--
my benigns are great.
I have a couple of
malignants here,
but I'm telling the person
they don't have cancer.
So that's if I try it with
m equals 0 an c equals 12.
And you just keep trying.
And the idea of a neural
network, that's what it is.
The process of training that
we call it is just trying,
and trying, and trying
different values,
calculating the loss
each time, figuring out
what you're going to do to
reduce the loss the next time,
and then try that value.
And keep going until you get
a decision boundary which
gives you a very low loss
or a very high result.
Now, in this case, obviously,
with two dimensions,
we say, hey, when
m equals minus 1
and c equals 20, we've got
a great decision boundary.
But that was only two axes.
And of course, the real
data looks like this.
But the real data
looks like this.
In higher-order math, instead
of drawing a decision boundary
like this, which
is bad, the reality
is it's possible for
you to draw a decision
boundary through multiple
higher-level dimensions,
like, in this case, five
dimensions of five features.
But if you've got 30 features,
it's possible for you
to actually draw a line
across 30 dimensions
with an equation that's very
similar to doing it in two
dimensions that we had here.
And so I'm not a mathematician.
I can't figure out
that math for myself.
But fortunately, the
process is exactly the same
as it was for the two dimensions
that I showed earlier on.
So we have your layers.
You have your weights.
And when you think about
your weights on those layers,
you're just going to figure
out what weight for this value,
what weight for this value,
what weight for this value
will give me my output.
I'll do my loss
optimization on that.
And in this case,
I've got three layers.
I could have 30
layers, or I could have
more, those kind of things.
And as a result, it will--
the loss optimizer feeds
back to the weights.
That feeds back through.
And that cyclical process,
as I've mentioned,
is the process of
training a neural network.
So in reality, this
ends up looking
like-- in the case
of the breast cancer,
you pull a biopsy on a cell.
A doctor will pull the
biopsy on the cell.
And then that biopsy is used.
The cell will be explored
under a microscope.
And then the features of
that cell will be extracted.
You know, we're going to take a
look at the radius of the cell,
we're going to take a look
at the concavity of the cell,
going to take a look at the
size of the nucleus, the color,
things like that.
And those features are
then put into a database.
And then those features
from that database
are then extracted into, and
fed into, a neural network.
We have an input layer
in the neural network.
We've got a number of neurons.
We've got fancy
diagrams like this.
But all that's going
on in that network
is that constant cycle going
on, going on, going on,
trying to find the weights
that will give you that line
that you draw through a
multi-dimensional space that
gives you the optimum amount of
values of one side on the line
and the optimum amount of values
on the other side of the line.
Now I do want to--
I always like to stress
here, and then ahead of that,
you'll have two neurons.
And the neurons will
be an estimation
of whether the cell is malignant
or an estimation if the cell is
benign.
So it might-- you give
it a particular cell,
and it might say,
hey, this cell,
there's a 5% chance
it's malignant.
There's a 95%
chance it's benign.
I almost said "divine" there.
I don't know why.
And so the idea, then,
is that this is something
that we want to build as a tool
that will help doctors, not
replace doctors.
So the idea is, think
about the amount of time
that it would take to
explore this data to take
a look at something if you
were doing it manually.
But if you get enough
samples, and you've
trained those
samples against ones
that have been labeled by a
doctor that a doctor says,
this is what a bad
cell looks like, this
is what a good cell
looks like, then you
can speed up diagnosis.
So that's the idea of how a
neural network actually works.
And how that fits
in, then, to the idea
of artificial intelligence
is that, if you
think about an artificially
intelligent application
is an application
that does everything.
It's your user interface.
It's your if-then code.
But it's also taking
advantage of machine learning
and may have a number of
different models of machine
learning, one for analyzing the
breast cancer, one for maybe--
I don't know-- analyzing the
patient's ability to pay--
I don't know-- all of
these kind of models.
So it's hybrid code
where you've built models
for making a decision
combined with code that you've
written yourself is your
overall artificially
intelligent application.
And then there's a process
called deep learning, which
is part of machine learning.
And that's when you
start really getting
into the deep neural
networks for classifying
and for understanding things.
My breast cancer one could be
either a traditional machine
learning or a deep learning.
I haven't really gone
that deep in understanding
the network behind that yet.
I've only really just
started working on it.
But I like to use that as
an example to illustrate
how the process works.
So all of this is
available through what
we call TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is your
programming API that
allows you to do these things.
This allows you to design
your neural network.
This allows you
to take your data
and structure it so it can be
run through a neural network.
And this allows you--
all those things
that I mentioned,
like those mathematical
functions for loss optimization
and all those kind of things,
are built into TensorFlow.
So you don't have to be a
mathematician to figure out
how to do them yourself.
It's a case of, you design your
neural network in TensorFlow.
And then once you've
designed your neural network,
you run your code through
your neural network,
and you hope that it works.
A lot of it, of
course, you're going
to have to optimize
your network.
And it's a lot of--
just like if you're writing Java
code or C++ code, I would say,
OK, for a particular
task, what's better,
a for loop or a while loop.
Sometimes you've got to write
both and figure out which.
It's the same kind
of thing with this.
You're going to design
your neural network based
on your input data,
train it with your data.
And then you can
optimize, and optimize,
and optimize to see what works.
So the goal is that
we've been building this
and open sourcing this to be
a machine learning platform
that's for everybody to
solve real-world problems.
So we started using machine
learning many, many years
ago at Google.
We've been constantly building,
constantly refining it.
I mean there's one thing--
I joined Google five years ago.
There's one thing
that they told me
when I first joined that I
thought it was really funny,
particularly at the time.
And that was that we
have cafes in Google
that serve food to Googlers.
And they actually have
been using machine learning
for many years based on
people using the cafes,
and based on wastage of
food, and that kind of thing
to predict how
much food to cook.
And so as a result,
they will overall
reduce the wastage of food.
And little things like that
have been going on internally
for many, many, many years.
And it's all of this
learning, all of this code
that we've been writing for
our own systems is what we've
taken and brought to the
world as TensorFlow, which
is this machine learning
platform for everybody.
So as a programmer, the steps to
build a machine learning model
are a little bit different
than what you're used to.
As a programmer, you might
get a design document
or a specification.
And then you decompose that.
And then you write
some code around that.
And maybe you write some
throwaway prototyping code.
And then that throwaway
prototyping code,
you'll learn
something from that.
And you keep going.
You keep iterating.
With machine learning,
it's different.
But in some ways, it's very
similar from the iterating
part.
So the first thing that you need
to do is gather your data, OK?
You've got lots of
different data sources
that your data might be in.
There's lots of different
ways that your data
might be represented.
Let me give an example.
Like in the breast cancer
that I've been talking about,
there's the size of the cell.
Say that size of the cell
might be a value from 10 to 30,
an integer or a long
value from 10 to 30.
That's probably not
very good for me
to train a neural network.
I might want to normalize that
data where the smallest cell is
a 0 and the biggest one is a
1 so I've got a span of data.
And then I can be a little
bit more intelligent,
that I know the ones towards
the bigger end of the span
are more likely to be
malignant, and the ones
towards the smaller end are
more likely to be benign--
things like that that you've
got to gather your data.
And then you've got to ingest
that data into the programming
language that you're using.
Most people, when building
with TensorFlow, use Python.
But we've been expanding
TensorFlow recently.
We've added Swift, and we've
added JavaScript recently.
And so think about
the data structures
and the ways of
representing data that are
available in those languages.
And you have to
ingest it into that.
But even further
on, one extra step
that you have to take as
a TensorFlow developer is
we've got something
called tf.data
where the idea is that, say,
for example, if you're a Python
developer and you are using
NumPy, that's great for you
to be able to train your models
off of, but it's not optimal.
It's not optimized.
If you then take that and
convert that into tf.data,
which then convert
that into tensors--
and the idea of
TensorFlow is the concept
tensors are a
mathematical construct.
And it's all about
flowing those tensors
through your neural network,
doing those calculations,
and being optimized.
So your first step, gathering
your data, you take it,
you stick it into your
programming language,
and then you optimize
that using tf.data.
And so then, the next part
is processing the data,
choosing your features,
and choosing your labels.
In the case of the breast cancer
that I've been speaking about,
there were 30 features.
I was able to train a
network that was just
as good at predicting a
malignant or a benign cell
using only six features as I
had from one that was using 30.
And the one that used
those six features
took a fraction of
the time to train.
To give another example, there's
a common data set out there
for house prices in California
that a lot of people
use for learning in
machine learning.
And one thing I learned when
I was playing with that one
that I thought was really
interesting was that, usually
when you're buying a
house, the number one
thing that dictates the price is
the number of bedrooms, right?
A four-bedroom house costs
more than a three-bedroom,
costs more than a
two-bedroom typically.
But when training
a neural network
to actually predict house
prices, the number of bedrooms
had no impact.
I trained a model, and I got
a particular set of accuracy.
I trained it by removing
the number of bedrooms.
I got the same accuracy,
but it was quicker to train.
Because often, sometimes,
one piece of data
is hidden in another.
In this case, the
number of bedrooms
is hidden in the
size of the house.
A four-bedroom house is
bigger than a three-bedrooms
is bigger than a two-bedroom.
And it was the size
of the house that
was the bigger
signal in determining
the price of the house.
So things like that is
processing data, formulating
it to optimize for ML--
so a lot of trial and error.
And that's really what
we call "data science."
Then of course, there's
training your model.
That's where you're going to be
writing your TensorFlow code.
I'll show some in
a moment, where
you're designing a network,
you're experimenting with it,
and you're optimizing
it for accuracy.
And then finally, and
probably most importantly,
is where do you use your model.
So there are a number
of different places
you can use it.
There's a serving environment.
We've got something called
TensorFlow Lite that will allow
you to run it on a mobile.
I'll demo that in a moment.
And then it's a course of
continually optimizing,
improving, and
updating your code.
So let's take a
quick look, first,
at gathering data, if we can
switch to the demo machine.
Sorry, before we switch to
the demo machine-- sorry,
go back to the
slides for a second.
My screensaver's there,
my beautiful screensaver.
Can we go back to the slides?
So a very famous
detective, Sherlock Holmes,
said "It's a capital mistake to
theorize before one has data."
And unfortunately, he's
fictional, but he's also right.
And so getting good data
and training your system
with good data is
very, very important.
So gathering data, it's
all about data science.
Data is the lifeblood
of machine learning,
I showed the diagram
earlier on where it's data
in, answers in, rules out.
So you really-- the job
role of data scientist
has grown massively
in importance
in the last few years, and
this is the prime reason why.
Because you can write crap code
that will compile and still
execute, right?
A programmer-- the
really good programmer
is the one who writes
the really good code that
becomes easy to maintain, that
executes quickly, and doesn't
have bugs in production.
It's the same kind
of thing in data.
It's gathering your data.
You can train a neural
network that's going to work,
but you could train it
on all the wrong data.
And training could take a long
time and be very expensive.
The model may not be optimized.
So it ends up being, data is
the new code in many ways.
So one of the
things that you need
to help you get your data
ready, of course, is good tools.
So one of the tools that we
have in Cloud that I like to use
is BigQuery.
So the nice thing
with BigQuery is
it gives you this massive
data warehouse if you've
got tons and tons of data.
In my breast cancer example, I
only had a few hundred records.
So I didn't need that.
But say you're training
off of millions of records.
BigQuery is really
great for that.
Because not only
does it store it
in a way that's
easily accessible
and it's quick
for you to access,
it also allows you to do
some analysis on your data
and then download
it, for example,
as something like a
CSV that you can then
turn into a training model.
And right now, even though
CSV is quite primitive,
it's the number one
data format that's
used in a lot of
machine learning.
So now can we switch
the demo machine please?
And just to give a quick look
at what BigQuery looks like,
I have a query running here.
So there's a number
of public data sets
that we've put into BigQuery.
And so these public
data sets-- and one
of the one that I've
been playing with
and I've been
having a lot of fun
with is there's a
baseball data set.
So I love to play
fantasy baseball.
And I'm now giving away all of
my secrets of how I beat all
my friends at fantasy baseball.
Because I've been
doing a lot of machine
learning stuff out
of the baseball
data set that's in BigQuery.
And shh, don't tell them.
And so then, the idea
is, like, BigQuery,
this is a browser-based
interface.
I'm doing it as a live demo now.
So for example here, I'm
going to search for pitchers.
And I'm going to search for my
third-favorite baseball player.
Can anybody guess who
it is from his name,
for pitcher first
name equals Felix?
I'm a Seattle guy.
That'll give you a clue.
But I run a query.
And there you can say, it
just took like 1.2 seconds.
It's gone through
the entire data set.
This is just a standard query.
It's a SQL query.
But it's given me the
data from that data set.
And because it's
SQL, I can start
doing interesting things like
that, like normalizing it
or whatever.
Or I could just take
the data, and I can just
download it and then do
all the fun normalization
stuff using tools,
or directly in Python
or whatever language I'm using,
to put it into TensorFlow.
So can we switch back
to the slides, please?
So the next step, then,
is processing your data.
And processing your data
is a little bit different
than it would typically be
because of how you sometimes
need to encode your
data to make it
understood by a neural network.
So the first thing that you do,
as I've mentioned earlier, is,
whatever your
language-specific encoding is--
Python, JavaScript
arrays, Swift data,
all those kind of things--
take a look at this URL,
tensorflow.org/guide/datasets.
That will tell you
the optimal ways
to represent your data
in these languages
and then turn it into tf.data,
which is a format of data which
is tensor-based, which
is then optimized
for running in TensorFlow.
But more importantly is how
you think about your data.
And let me give one example
for your feature engineering.
And this is unintuitive
as a programmer.
So say, take, for example,
I've got something that's
got four different classes.
And my breast cancer was two,
right, malignant or benign.
But say I want to classify
something that's got four
different possible classes.
Now, as a programmer,
I'd say, OK,
if something has got
four possible options,
the optimal way for me to
store that is probably 2 bits,
right-- you know
00, 01, 10, or 11.
Or maybe slightly less optimal
is it's an integer, OK?
I'll put it as an integer.
So it's going to
be 0, 1, 2 or 3.
But in machine
learning, you actually
use four integers to store it.
And you go, this seems crazy.
Why would I use four integers
to store a value that
could be between 0 and 3?
So the reason for this is that--
start thinking in terms of,
we want to run
classification on something.
Remember, we're
giving it the data.
We're giving it the answers.
And it's inferring in the rules
and giving us something out.
So in this case,
I would say, OK,
there's going to be
four neurons at the end
of the neural network.
And these four neurons are
going to give me a percentage
probability that
it is what it is.
Like, I don't know, pick
something that there's four of.
I don't know-- soccer teams in
a group in the World Cup, right?
So what was it?
It was England, Belgium,
Tunisia, and Saudi Arabia,
I think, were in one group.
So imagine if I was
building a probability
that these ones are going to
win that group in the World Cup.
Now instead of outputting a 0
for England, a 1 for Belgium,
that kind of thing,
it's a case of,
I have four neurons
that are going to fire.
And I want this
neuron to fire if I'm
predicting England to win.
I want this neuron to fire if
I'm predicting Belgium to win,
that type of thing.
And as a result, I
have to pass the data
into it that looks like that.
So when I pass the data in
for, these are the players,
this is the form,
this is how they
play in a certain temperature,
on a certain field, all
of those kind of data,
when I pass in the answer,
then I also want the
answer to be 1, 0,0,
0 when it's England
were good, 0, 1, 0,
0 when it's Belgium are
good, those kind of things.
So that's the pattern for
the neuron that I want.
So this process-- and
this is just one concept.
This is called One-Hot encoding.
But this is part of the
process of feature engineering.
So as a software
developer in TensorFlow,
these are the type
of terms and these
are the type of
concepts that you
need to learn so that
you can design your data,
you can engineer the
features of your data
so that you can train
neural networks around it.
So I want to give a quick
look at feature engineering
in Python.
So we can switch back
to the demo machine.
So the best thing to
do, I would say, is--
if you go to
tensorflow.org/tutorials,
this website teaches you how
to get started with TensorFlow.
And if I scroll down
here, these five links--
basic classification,
text classification,
regression, overfitting,
underfitting, and saving
and loading--
these will lead you to something
called a Colab notebook.
And the Colab notebook
looks like this.
And what's really neat
about the Colab notebook
is that it's something
that executes completely
in the browser, but it gives
you the full TensorFlow runtime.
And it gives you the full
TensorFlow code and API.
And you can even run
it on a GPU if you
want to do training on a GPU,
which is more optimized for it.
And this is something
that runs in the browser
and is completely free.
And what we've done is we've
built these number of tutorials
that will say-- for
example, in this tutorial,
it's like, if I want to
do a binary classification
around movie reviews, it
has all the code in there.
And it allows you to
step through that code.
And it will do things such
as the feature engineering
that I've mentioned.
Here it's preparing the data.
Here it's building the model.
Here it's putting in the loss
function, those kind of things.
And this will take you through
all the steps of, like, here's
a raw feed of data from IMDb.
And what we're going to do with
this raw feed of data from IMDb
is we're going to build
this classification
of good movie versus bad movie.
And it'll take you through
the steps of doing that.
So time is a little short, so
I won't go through those steps
now.
But all of this is public.
And I'd strongly recommend
to go take a look at it
and step through
these notebooks.
It doesn't take long.
And you'll find them all on
tensorflow.org/tutorials.
OK, if we could switch
back to the slides, please.
So the next step--
remember gathering
your data was the
first step, repairing
your data was the second.
The next step, and
the most important
from a programmatic step-- from
a programmatic point of view--
is training your models.
So first of all, when
you're training your models,
there's three
different types of chip
that you can use
in your computer.
We're all familiar with the CPU.
And a CPU, to me, is
like a Swiss army knife.
It's a chip that's been
designed to handle everything
in your computer,
managing your windows,
managing your network stack,
all of this kind of stuff.
Your code compiles and
it executes on that.
So as a result, it's
a general purpose chip
for doing just about anything.
So therefore, it's not optimized
for any one particular thing.
It's just like a
Swiss army knife.
The second type
of chip is a GPU.
And a GPU is kind
of interesting,
because it's a graphics
processing unit.
And a graphics
processing unit, they've
evolved greatly for
games over recent years.
But the things that you do in
a game such as 3D rotation,
the matrix multiplication for
that, all that kind of stuff
is actually very
similar to the math
that you would do
in a neural network.
If you remember earlier, I
was talking about the math
and calculating the weights.
It's very, very similar
to the kind of things
that are done in a GPU.
And of course, a GPU is
a type of chip that's
got lots of little cores.
And all of these little cores
are optimized for doing math.
And as a result,
for a long time,
the researchers who
have been trying
to optimize what they're
getting out of machine learning
have been using GPUs.
And it's a chip that
works really great,
but it's not designed
for the task,
like slicing a chili
pepper with a razor blade.
And so then, the
third one is a TPU.
And the TPU is a chip that we've
built and we've made available.
It's called a Tensor
Processing Unit--
so T for Tensor--
with the idea being
that this is absolutely
optimized for machine learning.
It's optimized for
processing tensors.
And as a result, it's like a
specialized knife, like a sushi
knife, in this case.
So this is a TPU and some
of the numbers behind it.
We get about 180
teraflops per device.
Bandwidth memory-- 64 gig.
The reason for that
high-bandwidth memory
is when you think about loading
data, processing data, loading
data.
So it really improves
your data throughput.
It's programmed via TensorFlow,
and it's now available in beta.
So if you use the
Google Cloud Platform,
you can get a machine in
the Google Cloud Platform
that uses a TPU.
And then you can just
rent time on that TPU
to do your training.
And one example that
we've done was--
there's an image classification
thing called ResNet where,
as you can see here, we
did a throughput of taking
real images to train in ResNet.
We were able to, with TensorFlow
1.7, about 2,500 images
per second with a TPU.
But then when we
preprocessed those images
to make them a little
bit more optimal,
that went up to 3,150 per second
being able to process on a TPU.
But the important
bullet point here
is the third one,
that the ResNet--
for many years, researchers
have been working on this.
And to train a
model in ResNet used
to cost in the tens of
thousands of dollars,
and then in the
hundreds of dollars.
And we did this one
benchmark back in March
where we actually tested it.
It was about $85 in CPU time.
And I was actually
working on this slide.
It was used in our keynote
at the TensorFlow Summit
that Jeff Dean gave.
And as we were working on the
slide, they came back and said,
they've actually
slashed it even further,
but they haven't verified
by how much exactly.
But I'm not allowed
to say the number,
but it's significantly
lower than this.
So we have a kind
of a Moore's law
in effect for the actual
cost for training,
where it's plummeting
dramatically.
And using TPUs in particular,
even though a TPU might be,
on per second basis, more
expensive than a GPU,
when you can do that
much more with it
and train the model
much cheaper--
and if you go to
this URL at Stanford,
you will see our first
benchmark submission
that we put around it.
So then the next part is
actually using the models.
So you've gathered your data.
You've processed your data.
You've trained your model.
How do you use them?
And so I'm very passionate
about mobile and using mobile.
But there is three
different things--
three different ways that
you can use machine learning
models.
So first of all is what
I've been talking about
is TensorFlow.
TensorFlow itself, it's designed
so that you can train models.
There's an API for
you to train models.
And it's a runtime for you to
execute them on your machine.
But you know what, if
you've trained a model
and you've got a nice, big,
fat GPU under your desk,
and you've trained a model
on that, and you can execute
and you can infer
on that, so what?
Not anybody else can
use the model, right?
It's great if
you're an academic,
and you're researching,
and you want
to show that, hey, I used this
machine, and I have this model,
and here's my benchmark.
But it's not very good for
you to deploy the model
for other people to use.
So we've been hard at work
to build two runtimes.
The first of these
is TensorFlow Lite,
where the idea is that
if you have an Android
device or an iOS device--
in an increasing
amount of IoT devices,
you've probably seen, we've
put demos out for Raspberry Pi,
where the idea is, if you've
got a Raspberry Pi device,
you can then run inference
on those devices.
And by that I mean you build
the model on your big, fat GPU
under your desk, or
you build it on a TPU.
And then you can actually
crunch that model,
flatten it, prepare
it for mobile,
and then deploy it
to a mobile device.
And then on that
mobile device, you
do not need any
connection to the internet
to be able to run
inference on the model.
I have a video that I'll
show later if we have time.
But it's a terrific example
of, there's a crop in Africa--
well, it's a crop all over.
But it's used-- it's
part of the food group
in Africa called cassava.
And we worked with a group
in the country of Tanzania,
where cassava was primarily
the backup plant for farmers.
They had their primary plants
that they wanted to grow,
but they had cassava if
their primary plant failed.
So if the primary plant failed,
you wouldn't have a famine.
But if the cassava
failed, it's a disaster.
Now the thing about cassava
that's really interesting
is that there is
a disease, there's
a blight that affects cassava.
But you don't see this with the
human eye until it is too late.
You'll see splotches
on the leaves.
It's too late by that point.
The plant is blighted.
And the blight has spread
to the other plants.
You just don't see it yet.
So as a result, a blight
coming in the cassava
can actually destroy
an entire crop
before you know it's
being destroyed.
So we worked with a university,
and we worked with some folks
in Tanzania, to build
a detector to say--
to train it on leaves and
say, OK, this is a leaf.
We don't know if
it's diseased or not.
But in the future,
we'll label it
if that plant becomes
diseased, and train it
on a bunch of these.
And it ended up
being able to spot,
on a disconnected device--
most importantly, it's
a disconnected device, so
no broadband connectivity--
that farmers can take
an old Android device,
wave it over a
leaf, and determine,
much earlier than you
could with the human eye,
if the leaf is diseased or not.
And if it is diseased, then
they can yank that plant out
before it destroys
the rest of the crop.
So little scenarios like
that have been empowered
using this kind of thing.
Train it.
You're labeling.
You're giving the data.
You're creating a model.
You're flattening that model.
And then, using
TensorFlow Lite, you
can then run it on an Android
device or an iOS device.
And then the third of
these is TensorFlow.js.
And this one, to me, is
also particularly exciting.
Because now you can use
JavaScript in the browser,
not just to run inference
on existing models,
but to actually
build the models.
So all those steps that
I was talking about
of gathering your data,
preparing your data,
training the model,
and running the model
can be done directly
within a browser.
So think about the
distributed scenarios
that are available there.
If you go to
youtube.com/tensorflow,
we've got a lot of
videos on there.
And I'm actually in the middle
of producing a video series
at the moment on doing
this in JavaScript.
So if you're a
JavaScript developer,
the basics of getting
up and running
with creating a neural
network, training it,
and doing inference in
the browser are on there.
So go take a look at them.
So I'm going to switch
back to TensorFlow
Lite for a second, which
is the mobile one that I
was talking about.
So the idea of how
that works is you've
built your model using your
big, fat GPU or your TPU.
And then we've created
a converter for that.
So the process that
I called flattening,
that converts it to
TensorFlow Lite format.
And then there's an
interpreter that we've
built for iOS, another
one for Android,
another one for IoT
devices, that will then
execute that model for you.
And depending on the hardware
that you're using, then
there are hardware
acceleration delegates.
So more recent Android
phones, for example,
are able to use some of the
hardware acceleration delegates
that are on there, things
such as the Pixel 2,
so you can have even
faster inference on those.
We've also tried to
make it cross-platform
as much as we could.
So that converted to TF Lite
format will convert it so it
can be run on an Android app
using Java, Kotlin, or C++,
on an iOS app, only
using C++ at the moment--
we haven't yet built the
extensions to allow Objective-C
or Swift to be used--
and then also on Linux and
some other IoT devices.
And there's some
ongoing stuff on there
and some announcements
coming pretty soon
about that to watch out for.
There's some really exciting
stuff happening in IoT.
And if you're an iOS
developer and you
want to use CoreML, then of
course you can use that too.
We've created a converter
to CoreML format.
So you can go off and use
Swift or Objective-C on CoreML
once you've built your model
and been able to convert it.
One of the neat things that
we always get asked about
is the size.
What impact is this going to
have on my Android device?
Well, we found that
the core interpreter
to interpret a model
is about 75 kilobytes.
Now TensorFlow Lite is in the
very early stages right now.
So in the early stages, what
we've done is we've built it,
and we've optimized it
for a number of scenarios.
And the first scenario
that we've been working on
is image classification.
So a lot of the common
image classification
models, all of the
operations that they use
are currently supported.
So if you train something,
like for example,
with MobileNet or
ResNet, and then you
convert that to TensorFlow
Lite, it will work.
But if you train something
custom that isn't those,
like for example, my
breast cancer classifier,
then that neural network
might use some operations that
are not supported.
And so we're continuing to work
on having operational support
parity between TensorFlow
and TensorFlow Lite.
But right now, with all
supported apps on TensorFlow
Lite, it's about 400 kilobytes.
OK, let me give a quick demo
of image recognition on mobile.
So this will be
image recognition,
if we can switch to
the demo machine.
And I'm going to run this on
an Android emulator, which
is a little bit risky.
So I'm just running my
emulator here right now.
And what this is
doing is that this
is capturing from the camera on
the front of my laptop, which
is emulated as the camera on
the front of an Android device.
And it's taking each frame.
And it's passing that
through a network
that's been trained to classify
1,000 different images.
So the output from
that network is
going to be 1,000 different
numbers, with each number being
a probability that
what you're looking at
is the thing represented
by that number.
Like, I think, for example,
number 55 is a coffee
cup, those type of things.
So of those 1,000 now, it's
looking at the dots behind me
here.
And it's classifying that as
a shower curtain, or a window
screen, or a strainer,
which is pretty good.
But I'm going to
do my banana demo.
So I'm just going
to hold this up,
because it sometimes
gets a little confused.
And if I hold this
in front of it--
can never know the orientation.
There we go.
And you see it's actually--
well, it was a banana.
There we go, 76%
chance it's a banana.
Oh, syringe, wow.
I don't know why it
thought that's a syringe.
My favorite is, I usually
stand in front of it,
and it gives me
something different.
I was an Italian
greyhound earlier.
I don't know why.
It must be my hair.
There we go.
I'm a strainer.
But thinking about
what's going on there,
there's 1,000 different things.
Remember, earlier, I was talking
about cats versus dogs, right?
That was two different things.
But here, there's
1,000 different things.
The model for this is just
a few hundred kilobytes.
It's running that
because it's been
flattened to run on Android.
And it's just a simple
Android application
that's reading a
frame from the camera,
passing that frame to the
model, getting the array back
from the model of the 1,000
things, picking the top three,
figuring out why
those top three are,
and then showing
it on the screen.
And then that number is
the time of inference.
So you can see it's about
1,300, 1,400 milliseconds.
But that's because it's
running in the emulator, OK?
I have my Pixel 2 phone with me.
If you want to see a demo
of it later on a phone,
you'll actually see it
doing this classification
in, usually, 30 or
40 microseconds.
It's that fast at
being able to do it.
The code for this is
completely open-sourced.
It's on tensorflow.org.
Go have fun.
Have a play with it.
Also, there's some
codelabs outside.
There's one codelab called
TensorFlow for Poets, which
will teach you all
about this and how
you can retrain this to
classify your own things.
Like maybe you want to classify
different types of flower,
or something along those lines,
instead of the 1,000 classes
that it gives you.
And it will show
you how to do that.
So if we can switch
back to my slides.
OK, so TensorFlow.js
is the next one.
And so if we think
about TensorFlow.js,
the idea with TensorFlow.js,
as I mentioned,
is that you can train a neural
network using JavaScript.
And you can then run inference
on that neural network
using JavaScript.
Now, I've been talking
about JavaScript
in the browser as one scenario.
But there's a second scenario if
you're a JavaScript programmer,
and that's JavaScript
on Node.js.
So if you have a Node.js
server, that server
can be used to run
inference for you.
Or that server can be used to
gather data and train things.
And where that, to me,
gets particularly exciting
is-- any Firebase fans here?
A few, cool.
So you are probably familiar
with something called
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
And the nice thing about
Cloud Functions for Firebase
is that they are a
serverless environment
that you can write code on.
And then that code will execute
in response to triggers.
So there can be triggers
in your application,
like maybe a user logging
in or a particular analytics
event happening.
And then code could execute.
But now, instead of traditional
JavaScript if-then code
executing, that JavaScript
could wrap a model.
And then you could run
inference on that model,
maybe to do a classification
or something along those lines.
So that's TensorFlow.js.
And if I take, a little bit,
a look at the code again
before I show a demo, just
remember the ML paradigm.
It's all about answers in,
data in, and rules out.
If you take nothing else away
from this, as a programmer,
start thinking in those terms.
Start thinking
about what scenarios
am I going to get if I put
answers in, and I put data in,
and I get rules out.
And I'm going to give
one final demo of that.
And this one is a tough demo.
So let's see if we can
switch to the demo machine.
All right, so this
is a public demo.
If you want to try
it out for yourself,
it's on js.tensorflow.org.
And this is "Pac-Man."
So if you're like me, if
you like Google Doodles,
if you remember, there was a
Google Doodle where we actually
created a "Pac-Man" maze
out of the Google logo.
So what this demo does is, in
the browser, you can see here,
there are four boxes
corresponding to up, down,
left, and right.
So what I can do is I can start
capturing images of me maybe
pointing up, or looking up, or
something along those lines.
And I'm actually going
to start doing that now.
I'll do it by pointing.
So I'm going to start capturing
some images of pointing up.
I'll move it around
a little bit,
because they all look
a little bit different.
I don't know, having
the dotted background,
if that's going
to ruin it or not.
We'll see-- so about 80 of them.
And I'm going to capture
some images of me
pointing right, la, la, la, la,
get about 80 of them as well.
Down is always the hard one.
I'm going to catch some
images of me pointing down,
bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh.
I can't see how many of them,
because it scrolled off.
I'll just guess it's about 80.
OK, and I'm going
to capture images
of me pointing to the left,
try to get my head out
of the frame, bleh,
bleh, bleh, bleh.
And remember, this is all
just running in the browser.
I'm using the webcam
on my machine.
Capture a bunch of them.
OK, so now I'm going
to train the model.
So when I train the model,
after I press the button,
you'll see a number
underneath, which is the loss.
So what that's doing is--
if you remember earlier,
when I was showing-- it's
calculating something, figuring
it out, comparing
it with the results,
seeing how well it did,
seeing it did really badly,
try something else,
and keep going.
And so it will keep going.
And you'll see, the loss
should keep reducing.
So there, now the loss is bad.
It's going down, down, down.
So now the loss is really tiny.
So that's telling me
that of all the frames
that I've captured, very,
very-- it's built a model where
it can predict like
99.999% accuracy,
it thinks, that if I give
it a frame, of what that is.
So let's put that in action
and try playing "Pac-Man."
So I'm going to play.
And I'm going to
point to the right.
Come on, Pac-Man.
There, he's going to the right.
I'll point up.
He's going up.
Ah, down, down, down.
oh, it was this hand
I used, wasn't it?
Down-- there we go.
I forgot I changed hands.
And now if I-- ah, he got me.
But even you'll
see the highlights
if you don't look-- if you look
at the highlight on the images
itself.
And you'll see it's actually
detecting, there's a right.
This is hard, because
I have to switch
hands, that kind of thing
that narrows it down.
Come on, go left, Pac-Man.
Eat.
Go, go, go.
There we go.
Whoops.
Ah, I'm going to die.
Quickly switch.
No, too late.
But as you can see
here, this is just--
this is entirely open source.
So if you want to play
with the code yourself--
we can switch back
to slides, please.
So what I've done here is I
just captured those images live.
I trained the model with
those images in the browser.
You can see it only
took a few seconds
to get a reasonable accuracy.
And then we ended up being able
to play "Pac-Man" really badly.
OK, so finally then, the
last part to think about--
and particularly thinking about
the future now is a real-world
machine learning system--
is that all this stuff that
I've been talking about,
building models and
all that kind of thing,
is that tiny little
box in the middle when
it comes to production.
So when it comes--
to be honest, as an industry,
we're still in the infancy.
There's still lots of
opportunity out there.
And our ML code that we've
built is that little box
in the middle.
There's all these other things
that you're going to need.
And I'm going to focus on
the ones on the right here,
which are the serving
infrastructure and monitoring.
So if you want to
build something that's
production-ready, of course you
need a serving infrastructure
that will allow you
to do it at scale.
You need monitoring to make
sure you're doing it right,
and all that kind of stuff.
And so I would
recommend you go take
a look at TensorFlow Serving.
So just a few weeks ago, we
released TensorFlow Serving.
The idea, it's a
server infrastructure
for deploying models
and allowing people
to access your models via the
web in a scalable and secure
way.
And the idea is keep
your traditional server
architecture, keep your
traditional request-response
model.
The demo that I just
showed, of "Pac-Man,"
that actually downloaded
an existing model,
MobileNet model, of
image classification.
And then I retrained the final
layer for those four classes.
But the original model
that was downloaded
that does most of the
work was something
that got served to me out
of TensorFlow Serving.
And as a result, I can actually
be able to deploy that model
and retrain it as we just did.
So take a look at
TF Serving for that.
So with that, this is
the theme that we're
working on for TensorFlow.
We're all about really trying
to make machines intelligent
and improve people's lives.
We've open-sourced this so
that you can build on it.
Think of the scenarios that
you couldn't previously
do as a programmer.
Think of the things that you
can't do with if-then code.
And you may be able to
do that with data in,
answers in, being able
to infer rules out.
So with that, I just want
to say thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]